and I want to ask you about the new
album oh which you said is a
Reconciliation of your relationship with
the church yes
what was it before what is it after I'm
very interested in your view on God and
spirituality and Faith yeah man
um
why I hate this podcast
it's like we'll laugh tell us something
about God it's like that's a good
subject get me in trouble
um
dude it's like
when I was four two do I have time to
tell this full story because I want to
share it in like it's detail oh yeah my
daughter
is just turned 15. okay
last year she started going to this
little church back in this little
Country Road a little bit of church in
fact it's a church that takes School
takes place in a school auditorium and
the school is kindergarten through 12th
grade right little bitty Church Little
Country Church 20 of the 100 members are
kids from her high school and I was like
this is last summer and I'm like when I
was 14
the summer of that summer was the last
year that I ever attended a church I got
baptized that same summer and caught my
first robbery case that same summer nice
so I'm all these feelings are coming
back up in me as she's like pounding me
because you know what people do when
they find a church you know gotta come
you gotta come it's like what they do
and I think that's cool so I was like I
should go so I go because I'm a father
you know what I mean you support your
kid and like I tell people if the kid
wanted to play [__] Cricket
ought to learn about crickets you know
what I mean like I'm in like you know
what I mean like I would have read a
book on soccer soccer for dummies if the
kid want to play soccer
so I'm like I'm going to church and when
I show up I'm like it was the first time
in a long time that I didn't I wasn't
mad at the church you know because like
there's so much like there's just so
much room for error and that whole
belief system I don't get too deep into
that because I'll get in trouble but
it's just it's just weird
and I was just in there like and I grew
up a Christian kid I got a cross on my
face you know what I mean and but I was
like I started looking at it from the
people not the preacher and I was like
why are they here
and that changed my perspective of the
church that afternoon I was like man
these people's intention is pure at
least in this little building they're
coming in here trying to cleanse
something they're trying to be better
people they're trying to set an example
for their children core principles of
Life moral compasses like they're not in
here to create this is like truly a safe
space for these people like this is like
and it made me think about why did I go
to church when I was that age what drew
me to the church and it was all my
friends went why did I get baptized and
what led me to then of course I spent 10
years after that in jail reading nothing
but religious material I mean I read
about everything you I never got I
didn't get my GED until I was in my
mid-20s in jail I'm a completely
uneducated man if you had to ask me what
grade I completed I'd say like seventh I
think was the last grade I actually like
graduated to the next grade you know
what I mean so
I'm talking to Bailey about all this
stuff and when we leave that church that
next day I'm like yo you won't believe
this kid but
I just go to a little church like this
and I got baptized when I was your age
and I had a bunch of homies and I went
on to could have went one of two ways in
life and I went to the wild route so
and she kind of didn't believe me and I
was like no I'm telling you dude it's
like the same church it was called
Whitsett Chapel Baptist Church it was on
this little Country Road in the back ass
Antioch between Antioch and Donaldson
sat across from the lake finally one day
I'd take her I'm like I bet the
building's still there
where I pulled up the building hasn't
changed at all wow like I think they
added a carport that I didn't put on the
album cover like literally a carport you
know like like for some sweet old lady
that like it's a hundred person Church
and um
when I left there I wrote probably a
hundred songs at that point towards my
debut country album
and I realized
that I wasn't writing in the spirit that
I liked to write in I was looking for a
hit I just came off a couple of hits
like real hits like life-changing hits
and I was like I was looking for a hit
and when I was driving that day I was
kind of praying because I'm a man of
prayer and I was like
I called my producer and I was like I
want to start from scratch on this album
and I had a song called going to church
in a song called hungover in a church
view that I wrote through all those
songs
and I was like what if we make that the
first song in The Last Song and we tell
a story
book open book close and we tell the
story of this album and we call it going
to church and he was like
what's the name of that church you went
to I was like what's a chapel he said we
need to call it Whitsett chapel and you
need to write that album and I wrote in
concept out like I scrapped all these
songs the record label is called like
mad at first or like yo we'd already
picked out singles we'd sent this to
radio like you got some hits and I was
like
give them to whoever wants them man I
can't sing them with conviction you know
what I mean I was like this is the album
and they you know I'm in Creative
control and they love me and they were
like we trust you sight unheard I just
turned the album in and they listen
and the head of the label Jonathan Loba
who changed my whole life I love you low
but calls me and he's like in tears he's
like yo this is this is like
he's like I'll never forget him saying
this because I hope he's right he said
you're gonna get nominated for a Grammy
for this house wow he was like this is
special this is like the president of
BMG he's like this is so the right thing
to do and nobody questioned it and it
was like my reconciliation came from
like
I still think what the church is doing
to answer your question directly I still
think what they're doing is wrong
but I think that the spirit of which
people go to these churches is more and
I try to judge Things based on intent
and I never seen the intent like I did
watching my daughter and them go to that
church can I ask you we don't have to
put it in if you don't what do you think
is wrong about the church well you can
put this in I just think that they're
you know
I think that you you can't Pander to
people that that to think that we're all
stupid enough not to be free thinkers
and I hate that this like out like Jesus
and the church is going to die again
Jesus is going to die all over again if
they don't find a way to portray him the
way he was historically known to be
not the version of which y'all let
Constantine and all these people come
together and figure this out under the
Constantine I read the Constantine sword
book about how this all came together
it's like when you look at that stuff
it's like if you look at the history
facts of Jesus which I think favor
Christianity in this weird way when you
look at those that dude is not the dude
y'all have turned him into like y'all
have Americanized Jesus and used him as
a way of not only propaganda but you've
weaponized God you have weaponized God
you know what I mean it's like that was
the opposite of who Jesus was the same
people that you were you were like
criticizing and going against are the
only people that Jesus had a
relationship with in the Bible
you know what the first miracle was in
the Bible pop quiz
the first miracle talked about in the
whole Bible
he turned water into wine for his mother
at a wedding reception
alone regardless of how you feel about
Jesus if you believe in it or not to the
side
his mother comes up to him so she knows
he can do crazy [__] right because she
walks up like yo I need a favor right
imagine this right you know when Jesus
was like and he calls a woman he goes
what woman in the Bible
shows me he's a Little Bit Sassy yeah
right you know what I mean
and she goes
in so many words can we I need a party
trick here yeah like [__] this is
like a really wack party like she only
talks to God when she needs a favor yeah
she only talks guys when she needs a
favor right she's like yo can you like
do something about this
he says it's not my time which leads me
to believe that she's probably seen a
resurrected squirrel or something I
don't know you know what I mean she
knows he can do something
and she hits him with the please and
just like any other good son who loves
his mom
turns water into wine
you're telling me this dude gives a [__]
about gay people
um
like you're telling me that's what his
Focus was in life at that era like
that's something he'd be concerned with
in this era of life
this dude [__] first thing he did was
a party favor and then if you look at
his history he did nothing but protect
Town [__] prostitutes people in jail
like the famous story of the throwing
stones let who without sin cast his
first stone he was protecting a
prostitute
um
Pharisees come into the temple at one
point they ask him about an adult an
adulterer dude having an affair right
and that's when he does the
he says uh he said in so many words and
I always the Christians get so mad when
I [__] [__] y'all anyways and he's like
you know he's like so many words he's
like hey man you know what about this
girl over here she's cheating on her
husband he goes
you only never [__] around on your
girl
literally that's what he says in the
Jesus ways like he ain't never you ain't
never cheated on your [__] ever
and these dudes are like well he's like
shut the [__] up
he never looked up from the dirt it says
in the scripture that he was drawing in
the dirt doodling is what that relays
down to he was just [__] around in
the dirt with a stick never even looked
up at the fair she was just like you
y'all [__] come on dude you're
cheating on your girl too leave that
girl alone it's crazy but then somebody
like my wife's the first person I watch
Christian women
Christian those kind of Christian women
persecute
it's like man that's the opposite of
what that dude was doing so that's my
problem with the churches like even if
we just go by the four books that y'all
call the only four accounts of him
this dude ran around with 12 thugs if he
was here today he'd be on a [__]
Harley he'd be going to a bar yeah you
know what I'm saying it's like
I do for this he flipped the table over
in the temple you remember this story
and he said don't make a merchant of my
father's house yet every mega church in
America sells CDs and books and [__]
coffee yeah there's Starbucks in these
places it's like they're so picky and
choosy the church is so like well hold
on it fits our agenda to really nail in
on this one thing that was said in
Leviticus right but we're gonna you know
it's like I thought we were focused on
Jesus anyways that's like the focal
point here I'm sorry I went over there
no the reason I was asking you is if
there's a this is a weird comparison but
it feels like when you've talked to God
in your songs it reminds me of DMX when
DMX would talk to God in his songs right
and maybe this is me projecting but
there's like um
like a I don't know if I'm worthy
like feeling I get from listening to it
maybe that's me again projecting my own
[__] but I've I was curious listening to
this and listening to save me and only
talk to God when I needed favor like
what is your relationship with God and I
don't know if that's why it affects me
so deeply maybe I feel that deep down
right but I've listened to DMX as a kid
same thing I feel now I can feel moved
like man I feel that way yeah well it's
like to me I'm just it's more of a like
I call it a sinner's prayer is what I'm
doing my music is just coming to terms
with like as a part of my recovery from
the stuff that was killing me which I
don't talk about
my recovery much because the recovering
purists would say that I'm not sober and
I shouldn't talk about it and I respect
those people so much right the people
that really almost like they can't live
that way but it's like for me how I had
to get off the codeine that was going to
kill me like Cody was gonna kill me for
sure
it took like me understanding the need
for a higher power yep like for me
personally I know it's not for everybody
but I needed to believe that there was
something because Jason if he's solely
in charge I'm [__] I'm in a lot of
trouble here Jason's he's in a dark spot
up here man that dude's that dude get
really really sad but it's like
believing in that you know what I mean
and then looking at these people and
being like Yo dude we not like if what
y'all are saying is God what I'm reading
feels a little different than like my
prayer to God is like yo if you're who
they say you are is there a spot for
[__] like us with you or no
because these people are sure making me
feel like we're not you know what I mean
he's not rejected yeah yeah it's like
you know so it's like talk to me God
like are we cool yeah you know what's up
with me yeah like you know my heart but
also the Bible also says that there will
be plenty of people that'll that he'll
tell them you think you know me but you
don't and there'll be people that you
know what I mean it's like so I always
joke that a lot of these pastors gonna
end up in hell and I'm gonna have a big
old mansion with a smoking section up
there you know what I'm saying I'll be
the one with an open bar in that
[__] you know what I'm saying
thank God gonna do something big for me
I think that humans have been
notoriously uh horrible relationship
with power and uh when you put people in
power usually shitty things happen or
the worst part of them comes out right
and I would think that uh a lot of times
religion is used for nefarious intent
and uh that doesn't mean that the ideals
behind it or the intent that you were
talking about what those people are
seeking in it that salvation that
humility that inspiration like wow what
if I could be just 10 more like that
Jesus guy right what if I could be 15
more I don't got to be him but if I
could just increase my kindness a little
bit if I could judge my neighbor a
little bit less like and I think every
time I've been in a church and I've felt
that from the people in there it was
beautiful
oftentimes wasn't necessarily what the
pastor was saying but it was the people
submitting themselves that I found so
profound and I find that even when I go
to
concerts as silly as that is like seeing
someone submit themselves to someone
else who makes them feel fantastic or
feel sad oh yeah or feel anything right
so
I understand your your feeling about it
and maybe if you had a talk with a
pastor he might be like yo you want to
something bro yeah a few of them
man I'm telling you I've had more
pastors reach out since Whitsett Chapel
and like just like speak out and go hey
man you might not some of these
Christian people might be against your
message right now but I think more
people are hearing about God through
your music than people have heard about
God in a long time he's like and I think
you're talking to people about God who
otherwise would have never heard about
them at all so them hearing about them
in any way is kind of because they might
feel immediately rejected kind of like
how you feel for sure you just
automatically feel like yeah I don't fit
that mold for that that particular thing
you know and the problem I do have as
you say that is that the people that are
like Jesus is the only way I get that
like he's the way the light I understand
the scripture but
like you just can't take away my free
thought here like you just can't leave
me to believe like Jesus is a piece of
this puzzle I had a lot of work I need
to do you know what I mean